>> I MAKE A JOKE, I SAY WHAT IF
YOU SHOVE A DRILL UP YOUR BLEAK.
THEN I MAKE A JOKE, WHY THAT
DRILL?
MIKITA, GO WITH THE MIKITA!
WITH THE GUY WROTE BACK, HE SAID
I'M SORRY, I HAD A TOUGH DAY, I
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T HAVE THAT.
WHERE DID THAT COME OUT OF?
OUT OF NOWHERE, THIS MEANNESS.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A CLIP FROM
ADAM CAROLLA AND DENNIS PRAGER'S
NEW MOVIE, "NO SAFE SPACES."
COMEDY IS TO BE THE REALM OF
LIBERAL MEDIA, BUT THAT HAS
CHANGED.
TURN ON ANY LATE NIGHT SHOW,
HUMOR IS GONE, IT'S DEAD, IT'S
BEEN REPLACED BY SUFFOCATING
PROPAGANDA AND MINDLESS,
REPETITIVE SOCIAL CORRECTNESS.
CANNOT BE FIXED CUSTOMER CAN A
COUNTRY REGAIN A SENSE OF HUMOR?
IT SENDS OF ART, IT'S SENSE OF
DIGNITY, REALLY.
WE HAD THE CONVERSATION IN PART
TWO OF OUR INTERVIEW WITH
DENNIS PRAGER AND ADAM CAROLLA.
>> WHAT IF EVERYONE
SIMULTANEOUSLY STOPPED
APOLOGIZING, STOPPED
BACKPEDALING, STOPPED WALKING
BACK TO EAT WHEN THEY WERE
QUOTING WINSTON CHURCHILL AND
THEN THEY HAD TO
APOLOGIZE AFTER QUOTING
WINSTON CHURCHILL OR WHOMEVER,
WHATEVER.
WHAT IF IT ALL STOPPED ON MONDAY
QWEST MARKET THERE WOULD BE NO
MORE BUSINESS ON TUESDAY FOR THE
PEOPLE.
>> EXACTLY.
IF WE DID IT AND WE PROVIDED
A UNIFORM FRONT AND SAID NO, I'M
NOT GOING TO APOLOGIZE, IT WAS A
JOKE, OR YOU TOOK AT THE WRONG
WAY, OR I MEANT IT, LIVE WITH
IT, THIS WOULD END IMMEDIATELY
END IMMEDIATELY.
>> Tucker: LET'S DO THAT.
YOU THINK BECAUSE YOU SPENT THE
LAST YEAR WORKING ON THIS FILM
ABOUT THIS TOPIC, IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO HAS DONE THAT,
OTHER THAN YOU ALL, WHO IS
STRONG, NORMAL, AND I'M SORRY
I'M NOT GOING TO APOLOGIZE?
>> DONALD TRUMP.
AND THAT'S WHAT DRIVES THEM
CRAZY.
HE JUST MARCHES ON, DOES HIS
THING, OVERWHELMINGLY IT HAS
BEEN GOOD FOR THE UNITED STATES
AND THE WORLD.
HE HAS HAD SOME RIDICULOUS
THINGS, EVEN SOME BAD THINGS
FULLY ACKNOWLEDGED.
NEVERTHELESS, HE DOES NOT
APOLOGIZE TO THE LEFT.
HE IS THE ULTIMATE NEMESIS OF
THE LEFT BECAUSE HE DOESN'T CARE
WHAT THEY SAY, AND I HAVE SAID
OFTEN, I'M A RELIGIOUS GUY, AND
I HAVE SAID THERE IS MORE FEAR
OF THE LEFT IN AMERICA THAN FEAR
OF GOD.
THERE IS MORE FEAR OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EDITORIAL
PAGE THAN FEAR OF GOD.
EVEN IF YOU ARE AN ATHEIST, YOU
CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRUTH OF
THAT.
THAT WHEN YOU BUST THAT FEAR,
IT'S OVER.
THEY WISH THAT THE FEAR WILL
WORK.
THAT'S WHY THEY GATHER AROUND
YOUR TABLE AND SCREAM AT YOU,
BECAUSE THE PREVIOUS TACTIC
DIDN'T WORK, SO THEY KEEP UPPING
IT.
BUT AT A GIVEN POINT, IT WON'T
WORK AND THAT'S THE HOPE THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND T
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND E
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND I
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND S
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND A
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND V
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND C
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND O
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND S
CYCLE TAKING PLACE ON THE
PART -- NOT OF LIBERALS.
BUT ON LEFTISTS.
IN OUR FILM, ALAN DERSHOWITZ
SAYS AS A LIBERAL, A DEMOCRAT,
AN AMERICAN, A JEW, I FAR MORE
FEAR THE LEFT DONE THE RIGHT.
>> Tucker: HOW LONG DOES IT
LAST QUESTION MARKS BIGGER THERE
IS A SIMPLE THING WE CAN DO, I
THINK WE ARE ALL GUILTY OF DOING
IT.
I LISTEN, I WATCH HER SHOW, I
LISTEN TO YOUR SHOW RELIGIOUSLY.
YOU GUYS DO IT AND I THINK IT'S
UNCONSCIOUS AND WE ALL DO IT,
WHERE WE SAY, HE LOOK, HERE ARE
MY THOUGHTS ON IMMIGRATION AND
THEN YOU STOP AND YOU GO,
HISPANICS ARE GREAT PEOPLE, I
WORK WITH MANY HISPANIC PEOPLE,
I HAVE NO ILL WILL IN MY HEART
TOWARDS HISPANIC PEOPLE, THEN
YOU GO AHEAD AND TALK ABOUT
SECURING THE BORDER THAN YOU DO
THIS THING WHERE YOU GO, A
FEMININE ISSUE, I MARRIED, I
HAVE DAUGHTERS, I LOVE THEM
DEARLY, I DON'T ABUSE MY WIFE
RITUALISTICALLY.
WHY DO WE HAVE TO PREFACE
EVERYTHING WITH EXPLAINING --
I'M NOT AN ARSONIST, I'M NOT A.
HERE ARE MY VIEWS.
I'M NOT A RACIST.
OF COURSE YOU ARE NOT A RACIST!
YOU'RE NOT A RACIST, I'M NOT A
RACIST IN THEORY.
I MAKE A FEW OFF-COLOR JOKES.
MY POINT IS, WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO PREFACE EVERY TALKING POINT
WITH I'M NOT MISOGYNISTIC, I'M
NOT HOMOPHOBIC, I'M NOT RACIST.
WE ARE NOT!
THIS IS INSANE THAT THEY HAVE
TALKED US INTO HAVING TO PREFACE
EVERY TALKING POINT WITH "I HAVE
NOTHING AGAINST HOMOSEXUALS,
MANY OF MY BEST FRIENDS ARE.
DENNIS IS A GODFATHER TO A
HOMOSEXUAL COUPLE."
THAT BEING SAID, LET ME GIVE YOU
MY THOUGHTS ON GAY MARRIAGE.
THIS NOTION THAT THEY TAUGHT
GOOD, FAMILY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NEVER BROUGHT ANY HARM TO ANY
GROUP, REGARDLESS OF
PROCLIVITIES, OR GENDER, AGE,
RACE, WHY DO WE HAVE TO START
EVERY REBUTTAL TO EVERY ARGUMENT
WITH, I'M NOT HOMOPHOBIC AND I'M
NOT A RACIST, AND I'M NOT -- AND
THEN YOU EXPLAIN YOU HAVE A WIFE
AND SHE IS, HONEY, ARE YOU HERE
BY THE WAY, THIS IS GOOD STUFF.
ANYWAY, YOU ARE MISSING A LOT OF
GOOD STUFF.
THE POINT IS LET'S STOP DOING
THAT!
GO RIGHT INTO THE POINT!
GO RIGHT INTO YOUR TALKING
POINT.
YOU ARE NOT HOMOPHOBIC, AND
YOU'RE NOT RACIST, AND YOU ARE
NOT XENOPHOBIC.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT, ACTUALLY.
>> YOU'RE NOT!
WHY DO WE HAVE TO PROVE THAT YOU
NOT JOB WHO WAS ARGUING WITH YOU
AND GOT YOU ON YOUR HEELS
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THEY KNOW YOU ARE NOT A RACIST
AT EVERY TURN.
>> Tucker: YOU JUST CHANGED MY